bueno el protocolo es algo clave siempre
en cualquier tipo de monarquía de la
monarquía británica ha seguido a
rajatabla la reina de saber se
caracterizó por sus formas protocolares
en todos los eventos en todos los
encuentros que como analiza usted este
protocolo que tuvo que combinar dos
verdad el unicornio y el london bridge
si efectivamente buenos días desde
madrid lo que estamos viendo es la
combinación de dos planes diferentes que
llevaban diseñados desde hace muchísimos
años no se puede dejar a la sorpresa lo
una cosa tan seria como son los
funerales o el dispositivo que hay que
poner en marcha cuando fallece un jefe o
una jefa de estado entonces ambos planes
llevaban diseñados desde hace muchísimos
años y por supuesto
en una institución que no deja
absolutamente nada sin prever estaba
prevista la posibilidad de que es una
gesta la reina falleciera fuera de
londres como si finalmente ha sido de
ahí que estemos viviendo la unión o la
combinación de la operación lo andan
brics y la operación millón y korn
decía estábamos viendo el traslado en
estos
momentos como espera usted que sea a
partir de ahora a nivel
protocolar la vida monárquica ya dejando
de lado este protocolo en particular no
pero bueno comenzamos una nueva era no
una nueva monarquía la de isabel segunda
estuvo marcada por un respeto absoluto
no de hecho eso destacan muchísimos
analistas que evaluación hace usted de
todo lo que fue la vida protocolar del
reinado más largo de la historia del
reino unido
la vida protocolar durante el reinado de
isabel segunda va muy en sintonía con el
reinado al completo de la reina ha sido
absoluta y totalmente ejemplar es una
fiesta la reina era una mujer que
siempre puso por delante la institución
de la corona a cualquier circunstancia
familiar o personal era muy cumplidora
con su deber y muy cumplidora con las
recomendaciones protocolarias que iban
surgiendo en su en su camino durante
durante su reinado pues lo que va a
ocurrir ahora
entramos en una nueva era termina la era
isabel comienza la era carlos esta nueva
era va a traer cambios forzosamente
tiene que traer cambios la jefatura del
estado la ostenta una persona diferente
con lo cual va a haber cambios el
protocolo también va a cambiar también
vamos a ver ligeros cambios porque el
protocolo al contrario a lo que mucha
gente se piensa es una cosa
absolutamente flexible una ciencia que
se adapta a los cambios de protocolo
está para ayudar no para poner problemas
el protocolo está para comunicar
posiblemente el rey carlos tenga interés
en comunicar cosas diferentes y de
maneras diferentes a lo que lo hizo su
madre la reina isabel con lo cual vamos
a ver también ligeros cambios en este
protocolo